hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing inside note and that's probably
I love necessarily but no it's actually
a French player inside note means in
time trouble but sight note is one of
those words that sometimes I understood
by English speaking or native English
speakers because one of those German
words that really fit very well as
German has there was some construction
with the yeah combined denounce those at
times very long words they don't really
exist in English I'm an unsure if it
exists in other languages probably it
does doesn't happen quite often that
something is completely unique in a
language I think as they always relate
almost always related languages but ok
I'm not I'm not an expert of course so
anyway um here we go with the English
opening and then playing this funny h5
line which is dangerous it has been
proven time and time and again but I
have also lost many games I have to say
from very good positions most of the
time in just the case of yeah sometimes
the position being ok but it is also
yeah I mean as sharp as it gets
so before by white yeah I don't know do
I want to take on g3 here or not it's
tough to say the thing it could open up
the F volume he will very likely take
with the pawn hmm
what is he doing to do b5 yeah Wow yeah
it's just very difficult okay I ended up
with the idea to play Bishop g4 in this
position let's do it
b5 oh my idea actually doesn't work at
all okay I I wanted to go b5 Knight
takes d4 which doesn't work at all
c5 okay and it's actually quite logical
it tries to make my bishop on a7 look
bad quite successfully actually so what
are we going to do 97 wow what a
difficult position taking on c5 and
doesn't make much sense
I'll just go into this 7 yeah maybe just
Queen to d7 I'm not sure the bishop on
g2 is so probably his best piece so as
there is some logic with the smooth I
know it is difficult to talk about logic
and such a crazy position but sometimes
there is some inherent logic even in the
most crazy proceedings
no don't don't see something great for
white so what's it doing in b5 you don't
Stu go before okay but that makes no I
can do it I can do it if he takes
quintics I'm threatening mate first so
97 is not not a problem yeah you know
that should be okay yeah now um okay I
will take that take first thing later
case now if I take c5 he has to take
with the deep horn yeah yeah yeah and
then canceling long is strong because
after info I can take on before that's
or not I thought if for a night before
night before Bishop takes if I check iam
that that works it must work yeah it
works
so if or does not it's not playable but
what else he doesn't have he doesn't
have an alternative I think that helps I
mean like Knight c3 I can also check on
before
I talked about some inherent logic even
in crazy positions and one thing really
am in play here was I can take it run if
I can castle unpunished
I would probably win it be winning or
very much better and that is what
happened okay I think Knight f6 yeah sv4
is such a strong or G forearm so strong
squares it's better than a passive
development one thing that is really the
case my a seven Bishop does not do
anything so I have to I have to still
activate this piece he cannot take rook
t1 and now that's it
the night covers f6 and he cannot ever
take the knight there's just no square
and there's just no piece that cannot
take the knight okay yeah it's always
super tough Ian these these positions
are so sharp I believe that this is
something that the engine will probably
if you analyze it in some depth and show
that black is better now I mean used you
already see at this very low depth that
the engine gives black an advantage I
checked this once but I never like
analyzed it in depth I checked it for
white and concluded that you cannot
guess already objectively speaking but
okay it's so one yeah crazy that like
anything can happen in a blitz game
important is that you actually have to
take on g5 here you cannot go h4 as
after 95 this is not that great this is
something that I checked checked at some
point I'm not sure if it was taking in
95 or 95 immediately yeah somehow h4
wasn't great the engine here shows f4 it
yeah again this is a good move I
remember that this is good
I got h form and i mean it's kind of
believable that white is in trouble
either
it's King position also makes them weird
this is a weird impression so I should
not take on g3 okay Bishop g4 is strong
one interesting a point is I'm
threatening h3 that's a very strong
threat okay
and this is the move this is a line that
the engine is this is giving here let's
see seven you know yeah it looks very
dangerous of course and black wins
that's some tough assumption - - okay
yeah I cannot believe it but I wonder if
my my play was terrible or not yeah
Bishop g4 roughly equal that's not bad
so see c5 is disliked even though it
makes a lot of sense in some way it
makes the bishop look bad but it's one
of those moves it's good strategically
but it has to work
Jim and this is a fantastic position
best movers details ePHI okay yeah but
after long castling it's like minus 5y
and him he cannot really save the
material that is that is winning
immediately and the same thing as this
this is also winning I can't take just
Queen h3 is also strong but this is a
simple one
yeah again very very very sharp position
and it's very very easy to make mistakes
now for both sides okay guys thanks for
watching